Breaking news.
It looks like Disney and Star Wars
didn't learn their lesson from South Park.
Are losing billions and billions of dollars.
They just handed over the franchise
to a Pakistani feminist activist.
Check this out.
First woman and the first person of color
to direct a Star Wars film.
It's set to be released in 2026.
You can say that the force is strong with this one.
Here's Charmino Baechenoy.
You know, I'm very thrilled about the project,
because I think, um,
what we are about to create is something very special.
And we're in 2024 now,
and I think, uh,
it's about time that we had a woman,
uh, come forward, uh,
to shape the story in a galaxy far,
far. Well, that maybe we should go a different route
than we did with Indiana Jones.
Indiana Jones.
Put a ticket in,
make a name again.
The main thing is to protect these characters,
make sure that they still continue
to live in the way that you created them.
But Mrs. Kennedy.
Bambi's a baby deer.
Baby deer. Put a chicken in Baker gang.
When is Disney and Star Wars gonna learn that
we wanna go to the movies and actually enjoy a movie?
We don't wanna turn on Star Wars and be preached to
about the patriarchy
or how bad men are,
are, etcetera.
Now, my thoughts on this is,
if she was the best person
available to direct this Star Wars movie,
and if she has A whole bunch of knowledge of Star Wars
and she's gonna give us a great movie
then. Awesome.
Many people are calling this yet again
another diversity quota higher.
And it's just gonna be another movie where Ray
or someone is a strong
independent boss babe,
but all the men are bumbling idiots
don't know what they're doing.
The plot is gonna be either horrible
or detrimental to the rest of the other movies,
and it's just gonna be another abomination
like the new trilogy was.
But you know what?
I hope I'm wrong,
and I hope everyone else
who's worried about this hire is wrong.
I hope she knocks it out of the park
and she gives us a Star Wars movie
that we all can cheer for.
But I wanna know
why was she hired?
Why was she hired?
Was it hired based on this?
Her knowledge,
ability to create amazing Star Wars?
Um, you know,
movies, fiction, whatever.
Or was it something else?
Let me know your thoughts down below.
Don't forget to like this video,
share it, or hit that follow button.
Until next time, love,
peace, and taco grease.
If this movie is horrible,
I guess you can say it really is the end of Star Wars.
And it breaks my heart to say, because I love Star Wars,
but the last couple of movies
have just been absolute dog water.